ما بقدر اسكت لما حياه بنت عمرها 11 سنه
تضيع رهينه صفقه تجار
اعضاء بقدر اسكت لما درك يخرط سلاحه بوجهي
وقت تكون عم دافع عن حقي
وحقه طموحي بالبلد ما بيوقف عند نشط اخبار
على التي في ولا هدفي بالحياه انه ضب
اغراضي
وفيلم اسمي حسن حرب وهول الاشياء ما كانوا
رادع بل حفزي لانه اتبنى التعدديه والتقدم
والعلمانيه كمبادئ
نضاليه جمعت لي مع ناسي شبهوني تحت شعار
الحركه الطلابيه البديله اللي خاضت
معركتها
الاولى اللي خاضت معركتها الاولى على ارض
الجامعه اللي انتم قاعدين فيها
هلا الحياه الانتخابيه بالجامعه محدوده
بلونين ابيض واسود ونحن حملنا مسؤوليه خلق
طيف الوان قدم لنا كلنا الخيار الثالث
استرجاع المجلس الطلابي واجا يوم
الانتخابات ومن بعد التعب وبعد الليالي
اللي بنا نوم من بعد ما استهزؤوا فينا من
بعد ما جربنا نحرر الطلاب من قوقعته
الطائفيه اللي كانت شالله حياتهم الجامعيه
وصلنا على اللحظه المصيريه ساعه وبتطلع
النتيجه وبتيجي لكم وحده مندوبه من هناك
حزب بتقول لي برافو حسن من 30 من خمس
اشخاص ل 30 شخص وصلت على نهار الانتخابات
كمان يلا كلها ساعه وبتوع من الحلم اللي
انتم
فيه وطلعت النتيجه
المنتظره سبعه من هي الميله سبعه من هيديك
الميله و
محسوبكم وبطبيعه الحال اجا وقت مرحله
ثانيه معركه الرئاسه بالجامعه مش
بالبلد وب 28 نوفمبر 2012 الساعه 3 ونص
بعد الظهر لقيت حالي بسياره بي ام مفيمه
نمره مجلس نواب
حوض من اربع شباب معزوم على فنجان قهوه بم
احد
الاحزاب اكيد ما كان بدي اطلع بس بيجيني
اتصال من خالي بقول لي جايه سياره تاخذك
من البزنس جيت بتطلع معه وما بتفتح تمك
بولا
كلمه
اطلع من بعد المشاورات الطويله على فكره
بس ما شربت فجان القهو
اقتنعوا الشباب انه انا مصر على ترشحي
للرئاسه وبنفس الليله طلعت
النتيجه مش لانه بحبوني كثير بيكرهوا بعض
بتعرفوا
كياته اللي خلاني اتحدى الواقع احلامي
بوطن جديد الفقير في غني والغني في فقير
الطائف اختفى والشعب صار زعيم والزعيم
مصريات راحت للابحاث وللثقافة
راديو فيل او اقعد كل يوم قدام شاشه التي
في شايف الدنيا قدامي خربانه وما اعمل
شي كل واحد فينا هو نقطه
ببحر بس القوه انه نعرف حالنا نحن اي نقطه
نكون بقل بحر
ننزل خذوها من وجهه نظري ككيميائي
نقطه حبر
زرقاء كبوها بكبايه
مي شو بصير لون الكبايه نحن اخترنا انه
نكون هالنقطه
وشكرا